mon coeur on l'a confectionné le jour de
ma naissance
parce qu'on dit que je suis née le jour
le plus froid du miel et que mon coeur a
gelé
c'est un peu bricolé sa marge j'aurais
voulu que ton coeur se solidifie encore
avant de lâcher dans les métiers
il y a trois règles que tu ne devra
jamais oublier ne pas bouger les
aiguilles
je sais ce qu'est ce que c'est mais
aussi maîtriser sa colère
la troisième celle dont je ne t'ai
jamais parlé la plus importante
je ne devra jamais au grand jamais
tomber amoureux
c'est pas ce qui brille c'est mon coeur
aux ennemis
je ne se portera jamais la charge
émotionnelle et physique que provoque
l'amour
extraordinaire